Canada's Sikh Community accused the
Indian government of being behind the
murder of Sikh activist Hardeep Singh
nejar he was killed by two masked gunmen
near a Sikh Cultural Center in June now
in an urgent statement to Parliament
Canada's prime minister has revealed an
investigation into possible involvement
by the Indian state
over the past number of weeks Canadian
security agencies have been actively
pursuing credible allegations of a
potential link
between agents of the government of
India and the killing of a Canadian
citizen Hardeep Singh nijar
Canada's foreign minister announced the
expulsion of an Indian Diplomat
described as the head of Indian
intelligence in Canada as a result of
the allegations if proven true
this would be a grave violation of our
sovereignty and of the most basic rule
of how countries deal with each other
the Canadian government has not released
any evidence the announcement and the
expel should raise several questions not
least if these are still only
allegations and the Canadian government
is asking the Indian government for its
help in quote getting to the bottom of
what actually happened how is it the
Canadian government already felt in a
position to be able to expel the Indian
Diplomat for seek Community leaders
ottawa's actions were welcome I think at
the moment uh we have no idea like as in
like the justice system itself has been
kind of I think failed in these moments
in the past where trade deals and
diplomacy and all these types of things
come into play so human rights if it's
actually at the Forefront of our agenda
then I would say like the justice system
should do its work its job find the
people that actually did this India
Canada relations have been tense for
some time in fact Narendra Modi was
reported to have complained to Trudeau
at the recent G20 about the political
space Canada gives to seek separatists
now Trudeau says he raised the
allegations of Indian involvement in
niger's killing quote in no uncertain
terms at the summit as well chabertansi
Al Jazeera Ontario
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera